the thing with investing is there's no
secret not that i found you know and
and i've been in it for a while now i've
studied quite a bit
the people who say they can make you one
percent a day or
these crazy returns tend to do so
through a course or through something
they're not actually going through the
proper
avenues to invest your money on your
behalf like if these people really had a
method for making these crazy
sums of money what they would do is they
would register a business they would go
through the proper avenues
i guarantee the money made through that
versus courses would be tenfold
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome to
coffeezilla today
we have richard from plain bagel
a finance channel on youtube that talks
common sense investing and this has been
a long time coming
ever since i uh besmirched his name and
me myself hey i'm i'm honored i
you know what it's like i was saying i
got so many laughs out of that
i shared it to so many friends myself
and patrick boyle we were talking
about good investing youtubers i know
what you're talking about it's like
half donut one donut finance or
something something like that
so i was like yeah now that i've
insulted this guy i better have him on
my show
actually yeah yeah so i can attack you
now and you know exactly
so you can pay the favor you're like
what are you t zilla or something like
that
i got him so why don't you start with
your background in finance how you got
involved what do you do
and then and then we can go from there
and talk about what's realistic what
what can you expect in the retail game
let's say you want to be a retail trader
so
let's get it yeah well well i made my
first million when i was not
um so i was about to say please no i'm
uh
i'm in i my wife and i actually just
bought a house so we're in bed right now
um but no it's so uh i've been working
in investments for uh only
around five years uh and it started i
went to university for finance
uh right now i'm currently actually
studying for my cfp which is
certified financial planner um but i've
been working as an analyst for about
three years
now for money manager here in ottawa uh
but that's about it like i mean i don't
have anything
exceptional in terms of experience i
don't have a crazy story like you know i
made
so much money through investing but uh
i do invest myself and i kind of started
making videos on youtube
because i had a lot of friends come up
to me and like we're in that age group
where
you know people start entering their
careers they're finally paying off their
student debts
and they're thinking about investing
exactly so
for the longest time i would sit down
and grab a beer with my friends and just
go over everything
like literally not trying to tell them
what to do but just say okay this is
literally what a stock is this is what a
bond is
and um that was kind of popular like a
lot of my friends came forward and asked
me to do this so
and i've always enjoyed making videos so
i figured hey like this could be a
youtube idea and
the rest is history i guess yeah now you
have like
200k plus subscribers
and you've got a bunch of videos on
basically
everything like fundamental finance uh
you talk about like forex trading you
talk about
all sorts of things but you come at it
from a very sensible angle which is
why i like your channel let but let's
start with
what you see to be maybe um
some challenges on youtube right now in
terms of these traders that are coming
on
they're telling people to buy their
signals group they're telling people
okay maybe you just need maybe i'm gonna
manage your account they're
overseas you know so that's even more
sure yeah speculative
um what do you see as the problem with
that
and can people expect to lose some money
oh no yeah of course
like 100 uh and
so there's a number of problems with it
on the one side you know
i've always liked to view i always
have this i kind of see this future
where investing is kind of treated like
our investment professional is like a
doctor in the sense of you know
when you go to an investment
professional you have this expectation
as to
the experience they have the education
so on and so forth
and the problem with a lot of these
programs is you have no idea what the
credentials of these people are
um and in the modern era like you can
say whatever you want about how much
money you've made and do whatever you
want
but there's no way to prove it and so
that's
you know in the age you can't even
manufacture broker statements
you can and that's the crazy like that's
obviously when you get into more
intense like fraud and scams but
even in the sense of just selling
courses um
and that seems to be kind of the most
prominent strategy and i get it like i
think a lot of
like courses obviously make a lot of
money like that seems to be the case is
you know you get a following you get
people to respect your
opinion and you monetize it you sell it
you tell people hey like i'm gonna give
you the secrets that i picked up
um and and sell it as a course
but you know the thing with investing is
there's no
secret uh not that i found you know and
and
i've been in it for a while now i i've
studied quite a bit
i have the cfa i've talked to thousands
uh hundreds of maybe not thousands but
hundreds of professionals personally
um and there's no secret strategy
especially not one that someone on
instagram picked up
because they you know just tried trading
for a few days
um so that that's kind of the biggest
one i've seen and then there's obviously
you know more intense scams where people
are actually stealing
people's money like you mentioned
overseas uh
i wouldn't recommend that uh the the
nice thing about investing with
professionals is there's a lot of
regulations
there to protect people for that
specific reason right so
you know going to a bank for investment
advice isn't sexy
and no you're not going to go and get
you know plus
20 return right that's the problem
people want
hey this guy down the street is
promising me 50
a year 100 200 percent a year exactly
but when they promise these returns they
also don't
uh follow the right avenues to give you
those returns right like
the people who say they can make you one
percent a day or
these crazy returns they tend to do so
through a course or through something
they're not actually going through the
proper
avenues to invest your money on your
behalf like if these people really had a
method for making these crazy
sums of money what they would do is they
would register a business they would go
through the proper avenues
and say hey like i have this perfect
mechanism for making money
i'm gonna do it for people through a
legitimate business and
i guarantee the money made through that
versus courses would be tenfold
because you would attract clients and
the more money you manage the more you
would take away as a fee
for managing their money and making it
grow by such a large amount
so i mean there's massive there's
there's funds opening up all the time
and attracting new investors with great
returns
and if you could even show a three-year
track record of really
crushing the market your ability to get
funds
goes to the roof of course yeah and and
when you go through that route but the
reason why they don't obviously is
because they they don't have to do it
that yeah they can't do it they don't
have that method that proves
that proven track record um and
sometimes they are doing
you know misleading marketing that if
they had a legitimate business
uh you know it wouldn't stand like my
company as a fund manager
can't go out and start you know posing
in front of lamborghinis and private
jets
and say we'll invest your money and this
will all be yours like we would be sued
in two seconds um but when you're only
selling a course that
technically doesn't guarantee anything
you know you have all the right
disclaimers you say
oh yeah like you'll get all this but in
the fine print you see
you know no guaranteed returns they're
not actually an advisor
uh any investment decision you make is
your own responsibility and not theirs
like they're not really taking any uh
like their words are cheap you know
how stupid is that by the way where they
can say
they can all the way down the sales
letter be promising you
riches untold glory you know
babies of women alongside of it and then
at the very bottom they can be like oh
yeah yeah this is not going to do any of
that
and yeah and in fact that like you're
what you didn't read the five brands
i know exactly and it's funny i i
actually it's funny too because uh when
i started the channel
uh i spoke to my company and they told
me to do the same thing and if you look
at my videos i also have disclaimer at
the bottom that says
the exact same the thing is is i
fortunately don't go on
i don't know the middle section where
it's like they actually do
promise it and then at the bottom they
say we know we don't promise anything
he's like whoa wait no no
you did though and now exactly you're
like
the thing too is is if a professional
did exactly that
there's a liability problem right so if
i as a registered business went
and said like we can earn 50 returns
and the next year i don't earn a 50
return uh in some circumstances
a client could come forward and sue me
and get that 50
from me from my personal funds because i
guaranteed it
but when you go through the trading
course route you don't have that same
responsibility that same liability
so it's it's a breeding ground for scams
and like it's it's not the only scam out
there but it's
one of the most common ones yeah it does
it does
seem to be now
i guess my question is look there's
what's the reason to retail trade
trade is a retail investor and um
how much experience do you really need
because one thing that surprises me
is that people are getting involved who
don't have
like they totally go all in on the
technical analysis stuff
what do you think about technical
analysis what do you think about i don't
know if you've gotten into like swing
trading at all
what do you think of these kind of more
pop poppy
forms of investing versus you know
trying to
use more mathematical
things right uh so like
i i should say like i'll say it this way
i i don't do swing trading so
when i work as an analyst i have always
worked as a fundamental
long-term investor so you know i'll be
the first to say that
i don't have the experience of swing
trading that being said
you know when you study for the cfa and
you go through this experience you do
learn about technical so
you know i have learned about these
indicators and things like that
yeah the problem is you know
you mentioned retail investors going all
in and i think that's
the problem is like i kind of see it as
like don't half-ass it like if you're
going to invest
yourself like if you're going to be a
retail investor who picks their own
investments
you need to have that education to back
it up and there's no course that's going
to give you that
education that experience in like a
12-week program
where you don't have any homework like
you don't have any practice throughout
yeah it's just like a social group like
and the problem is that's you know these
people come and tell you the opposite
these people say hey
like forget about the cfa forget about
university um
all you need to do is you need to pay me
500 bucks and i will give you this
step-by-step guide of how to make
millions trading from home
um and there is some
i'll say there is some value with
technicals um
my even my own company like we consider
it to some extent
but the problem is that many people kind
of rely
only on technicals and there's only so
much you can get from that
some people don't even believe there's
any narrative technicals and there's
very little research that proves that
technicals
work uh but you know just to clarify for
people who
might not understand how technicals work
it's just focusing on the stock's price
and just focusing on how many people are
buying how many people are selling
and those stats and uh you know it's all
based on
uh doubt the dow theory which basically
argues that there's momentum in stocks
when the stock price moves up
it is more likely to move up and things
like that but
you know these people kind of take that
and they bastardize it they make it the
only thing they care about
um and the thing with technicals is it's
very easy to pick up
and it feels very they're kind of
designed to make quick decisions so
if it's like the investing light like
it's very easy to make a decision using
technicals very quickly
with more fundamental research you have
to do a lot more work like you have to
study what the company does
you have to read their financial
statements you have to know their
management team
like you have to learn all these things
that can take days if not weeks to
really understand um so i think
obviously
technical trading when you have people
saying that they've made all this money
from technical trading
and it's easier to do in the sense of
you know coming to a conclusion about
what to do
it just attracts more people um so
yeah i think that's the problem i have
with technical trading like it's not to
say it's totally legitimate
uh you know there's some people who
apply it in combination with other
research
the problem is focusing solely on that
when you don't have a proven
method that's backed by a researcher or
backed by you know
because you can take a model that you
have and back dated and applied to the
past and
prove it rigorously and people never do
that it's always just like oh well i
learned this rule of thumb from reddit
yeah yeah yeah this guy told me it's a
great idea it's like oh you didn't back
test your
no exactly and and that's the thing is
it's very easy to back test and
yet no one seems to do it so that's it's
just it's too appealing you know it's
people tell you you can make money from
it and it's i wouldn't say it's super
easy but
certainly easier than more fundamental
research where you have to spend time
reading pages of
reports and things like that now do you
think the fact that maybe
so many retail investors are so
unsophisticated is the reason that so
many of them
end up losing their shirts in the stock
market because i what i've had people
come to me and say they go
no no no i really am making 200 a year
the problem is everyone else
just basically doesn't know what they're
doing and i'm like the 0.01 percent
i understand risk i'm i'm i understand
risk management and i
am the all-seeing uh you know baba
yeah yeah it's it's so
what i would say is i you know and and
same thing like i'm always very neutral
on things and
i i don't hate traders and i think there
are traders out there who
can make money maybe even consistently i
don't believe in the
fake gurus who make millions when
they're 21
but um you know there are people who
make a living from trading
and some companies even hire traders
full-time as a salaried position so
there is some legitimacy there
um but and part of that
is like you mentioned uh it's a hard
thing to learn because
at the end of the day a lot of trading
is emotional
um and like just as an example
there are these studies called the
dalvar studies and they're kind of
controversial in the sense that some
people don't really believe
the results that come from them but they
basically show that
year over year actively managed equity
mutual funds underperform index funds
that's kind of
the premise of the study and they
release the numbers every year
every year it's the same oh wow um but
interestingly
it's the number one reason for the
losses isn't actually tied to strategy
it's often tied to restraint of capital
meaning like someone gets a
car payment due and they have to sell
their investment early
and emotionally psychological factors
that impact these people ability
these people's ability to withstand
downturns
and i think a lot of people
underestimate the emotional
uh like task that is behind trading and
investing
um and on top of that like you have to
consider the past 10 years have been
exceptional for the stock market we only
have recently ended our longest bull
market
in u.s history which ran for a decade
and that only ended because of a
pandemic and since then
the s p 500 has continued to hit you
high still
so it's almost as if we're still in this
long arching
bull market um so
sure like during these good times some
people might make these returns
and you know be able to sell these
courses during this 10-year period
but i'd really be interested to see how
these people do
when we have our next downturn and our
next real downturn like we've had a 2020
kind of meltdown the problem is that
things have already recovered
and in the stock market not not the
economy the two are separate but
so that's the thing too is is you know
if people are emotional
during good times and some people don't
make money during good times imagine
what it'll be like when we have a
two-year
stretch when stock markets are in a bear
market
um that's a great point sorry is there
any way to know that somebody's returns
are real
in the retail trading world like to such
an extent that you would
personally invest richard you would
invest in them
because let's say they're claiming they
made a hundred percent and they can do
it year over year
and they that's let's say they go oh
look at my returns
i have four years showing 100 returns
are you going to believe that
and invest and what would it take and
has there been anyone who's like
like because what i see is people will
release uh you know
most people don't ever release a broker
statement occasionally someone will
and they go see if you doubt now you're
just you're just a skeptic you're just
you don't know what you're doing right
there's a problem when we live in this
photoshop world and there's so much
on the line to be up number one to
invest your personal money with somebody
number two
um for them to make money themselves
there's so much incentive to fake things
of course yeah is there some gold
standard for if they show this
we believe them there's like there's no
way it can be faked i don't
think so like i'm trying to think of
like you know what is a document they
could give
it is sad and you know that's the thing
is
there's really no liability there right
like you can virtually say whatever you
want and there's it's very difficult to
prove it
um because yeah you're right like so for
me
if like i'm trying to think of what i
would need and i can't think of like a
document that has like
a certified like you know stamp on it
that says this is legit
um but for me it would take that person
running me through
every transaction they've done over that
four year period
and give me the justification to those
trades
because a big thing with trading that
people kind of tend to forget
is there's a difference between a good
decision
and a good result uh
it's it's kind of something you have to
come to terms with is that you can make
the best decision in the world
or the smartest decision i should say
like you've done all the research
uh you do proper risk management and you
still lose money
but likewise you can also make the
dumbest
pick like you could throw dart at a
table and happen to make money
and so the reason why i say i want to
see their justification
is someone can say yeah i made 100
return i bought this i sold this i
bought this i sold this
it could be luck you know because the
people we hear from
are that 0.01 percent that are coming
forward because they got
they are that probability statistic the
other 99.99 we never hear from because
like who's going to come forward and we
seem like
oh you're saying that even like they
could have just gotten straight up lucky
they could of course yeah and and i
think that's like i
think of things like even just youtube
like you or i like
uh you know i have this channel sure
like i i
try to make good content but i i
consider myself incredibly lucky to even
be where i am right now
which is not a huge channel but i think
luck plays a
big part in returns uh so
and like i said you can make good return
or good decisions
and still get i shouldn't say like
terrible uh
returns because a good decision will do
proper risk management to limit
your your downside uh but you can
make terrible decisions and still come
out lucky because it's just like
gambling
right gambling as a whole is a terrible
decision when you think about it
some people still make a lot of money
that way some people do
the other thing that i was thinking
about even while you're talking about
like you know what document could they
show
the other thing is is there's ways to
get
really good returns that are actually
illegal and you'd want to
avoid like there are people who run pump
and dump scams
where you can make tons of money and
your your little self
fund or whatever can make tons of money
but
you're actually defrauding people and
it's illegal can you talk about what a
pump and dump
is sure yeah so it's it's one of those
scams you know when people think of
scams i think of someone coming forward
and saying hey
send me bitcoin to this address and i'll
invest it and
right then that money's never seen again
like that's a very cut and dry scam
the pump and dump is a bit harder to
identify but it's essentially
uh someone getting a big position
in it can be a stock in it
frequently is cryptocurrencies now uh
but they'll
buy a lot of this stock before anything
else and once they have this large
position
then they do the the pump aspect of the
fraud which is to basically go around
and try to convince people to buy this
this stock or this cryptocurrency
um and they basically go on a promoting
campaign
uh back in the day like this and i
should say this has
is a very old practice like this has
been around long before robin hood long
before
even facebook this has been a strategy
that's been used by fraudsters
but uh the idea is to go around and
market it uh back in the day it was cold
calling
these days it's it's social media and
tick tock i guess when signal groups are
huge because then yeah
army an army of people ready to invest
in whatever
you say you know groups are and what's
funny is you double dip because you can
get a paid thing on the other end
so they're paying you for
recommendations of stocks
and then i mean everyone's going to say
i never do that
uh then what you can do is you have this
legion of people willing to
if you have a you know a a low volume
low cap enough stock
you can move move it of course yeah a
little band of merry men
well that's exactly it and that's an
important point is it's always focused
on a
uh lightly traded investment so that's
usually a brand new company uh a tiny
company that barely anyone knows about
or
with cryptocurrencies a company that's
recently been ico'ed
um and yeah so and that's the thing too
and that's why it's
it can be tricky to to prove this in
on a from a legal standpoint is because
it's all about intent
right uh someone can in in a very legal
sense like
without causing any problems say hey uh
i bought this and i think it's a good
investment
and then later say hey i'm selling i
sold this i think it's a bad investment
uh and if you do that properly you're
not causing any problems
uh the idea of a pump and dump is the
intent from the beginning
is to accumulate the cement and dump it
as soon as you can
um once yeah let's get to the dump part
of the scheme
so you you pump it by selling it to all
your followers and then you
dump it and then you sell before telling
anyone is
is kind of the idea you don't need to
tell them to sell after you
because you don't care like you're
already out but usually because you have
such a sizable position and this isn't
always but
uh you yourself as a fraudster doing the
the dump aspect
uh you tend to trigger the sell-off and
what happens is because you're the first
out it's
the other people who follow the strategy
who get left picking up the losses
so when you mention these groups
sometimes uh
they're not even doing this for the for
the benefit of the group members
sometimes the group members are some of
the victims because
you know as long as the person leading
the group
gets their money out they don't care if
the group members lose their money
yeah because they should just been the
the faster of the group of the
of the herd you know been at the front
of the pack but
it's yeah it's it's something again it's
very hard to prove
but it's also very legal so if you
it's because it's uh market manipulation
uh it's
eroding faith and free markets and
uh you know so if you ever kind of get
the
you know the idea that someone's doing
this and some
groups are uh very forthright and
or what should i like they're very
obvious that this is what their
objective is like these are hidden
groups where they get together
and you know they're all in it together
but
when it comes to like these signal
groups it can be harder to prove and
you don't know what the intent of the of
the group leader is so
but it's probably something that happens
a lot more than we see
lawsuits for uh because in the
era of you know gurus people with social
media followings
it's taking on a new ugly form that's
very hard to track
especially when you have private groups
paid for gates things like that
uh yeah it's regulators aren't going to
be able to basically see what's going on
yeah and same thing like we mentioned
earlier when you're an individual trader
you don't face the same regulatory
overwatch as someone who does a
regulated business
so if you're just selling a course that
you know
meets all the fine print and doesn't
manage people's money on their behalf
you might not have those people
breathing down your neck
watching your every move so it's kind of
easier to get away with those things and
some people don't get away with it right
like some people get caught and you hear
of people who were
self-made millionaires getting caught up
in frauds all the time
but they can get away with it for a
number of years before anyone notices
how would you intelligently inve uh
assess an investing opportunity
what would you be looking for and should
you be looking for anything other than a
professional
in sort of the age of the scam if you're
going to do anything but
trade yourself so
yeah not to like i said on the spot to
be biased no no for sure
well that's it and that's something i
was going to start with is uh like i
mentioned i'm
i work as a fundamental sort of value
tilted investor so that's kind of one
approach to investing
and i'm not going to stand here and say
that it's the only and the best approach
to investing but
it's one approach um and
it really depends on the approach you
take uh if you want to invest yourself
like i said though you can't half-ass it
like i think you need that education
i'm much faster to say someone should
seek out
a professional than i am to say that
someone should do it themselves
i just don't think a lot of people have
the ambition
and that experience in education to to
do it properly
because it can take time to manage your
own investments and if you have the
ambition
like all the power to you if it's a
passion of yours to
trade stocks and do this then great but
if you're just looking
to deal with your finances uh i don't
think it's the way to go for a lot of
people
because you need that you can't half-ass
it um
so in terms of how to so if you do
decide to do it yourself
and again this is my own uh biased
approach
sure but it really comes down to the
fundamentals like when i start with the
company
the first thing i do is i i learn about
the company like i learn what they do
and i read through their 10k statement
uh the regulatory filings that tell you
what the company does because you know
it's funny how many people i know who
will buy and sell stocks
and can't tell you everything that that
company does um
they actually a while ago it makes me
remember uh
when when was pokemon go a thing i'm
trying to think was that 2018.
2017 maybe maybe well not really like
that 20
15 or 14. really man uh so yeah when
when pokemon go blew up i think nintendo
stock started like climbing upwards
because
you know people were like this is the
future of gaming and all that sure
and and then there was an investor
conference and
the nintendo management came out and
said hey like you know we don't really
expect it to be a huge financial benefit
because we only
own something like 20 of pokemon go and
the stock crashed
i think that's the dumbest thing i've
ever seen because it's like if you're
buying the stock you should know that
they only own
twenty percent of pokemon go like this
is also intense it tends to be public
information
yeah but you know it's it's so you need
to know what the company does and that
sounds so
silly when you really think about it
that you have to tell people that you
should know what the company does that
you invest in
um and again that's the fundamentalist
approach but
uh then it comes down to you know once
you know what they do
how much money do they make what's their
balance sheet like
how much debt do they have um and is
their debt manageable
and there's all these ratios that you
can look at in this area that that's
where that education comes in right you
learn about what to look for
what are red flags um and then once you
kind of get a grasp about what the
company does
how it makes its money and how much
money it makes in its business overall
then it's the economy right because you
can have the best company ever
and if the economy is not doing well
that company can still go under uh you
know think about companies like cruise
lines right now
um like it's you have the best cruise
line ever and it's not doing well right
now
so it's you know it's not it's a com
it's a lot of work to go through the
whole process but it's really not
that surprising like what you have to do
to really understand a stock opportunity
um and there's stuff like valuation as
well that comes into play and that's
more
uh technical in terms of uh like the
ratios you look at and understanding
that
sure but you know at the end of the day
you're really just
researching a company like you're doing
core research as to
what you're investing in you should
think of it as if like you had to buy a
small business in your in your town for
example
like some people look at it and they
think you know from the trader's
perspective it's like okay if i buy this
small business i can sell it
next or tomorrow for a bit more but
for most people if you had to buy small
business you would do your research you
would say okay what are they doing
how much money do they make what are
their assets and liabilities
it's that very fundamental research that
i think a lot of people get caught up
ignoring or just not putting the work
into to really understand those
those factors which are incredibly
important
um and i think too is when you do
understand
the company you invest in during
uncertain times like what we're in right
now it's a lot easier not to succumb to
your emotional pressures uh because
if you know that your company can handle
its debt
with a year without revenue you're not
as concerned whereas a lot of people
don't
have that understanding of the positions
they own buy tesla calls
some tesla calls boys no tesla's nuts
and it's it's it's funny like i you know
do you think of stuff like that
in a world where everyone's using robin
hood there are these weird stocks that
just did tesla make sense to you or
are you like so so what i'll say is
uh and again this is based on my
experience as a value investor
is value investors tend to try to avoid
the big names that are blowing up that's
just like kind of the approach
so it's not to say that if you buy tesla
you're going to lose money like i'm not
making that claim
i'm saying that i don't understand how
it's gone to where it is
and i personally don't invest in it
right now
uh just because i think uh so something
a lot of people don't understand with
stocks is the idea of evaluation um
you know people just look at a stock's
price and they might think a 20 stock is
cheaper than a 100
stock but you have to consider valuation
like
how much is the company making versus
how much is the stock
trading for and that's called a multiple
it's it's
kind of that that margin if a company is
earning one dollar
per stock a year and they're trading at
twenty dollars a stock
that's a twenty times multiple um and
tesla right now i think it's
price that multiple is in the hundreds
right now
so for every one dollar profit per stock
like if you take
sure net income divided by number of
stocks outstanding
and you take the stock price the stock
price is 100 over 100 times that amount
uh now the argument could still be made
that
uh you know tesla's growing so quickly
that those earnings will quickly catch
up
and they are growing revenues very
quickly but
i don't think a lot of people who buy
tesla stock right now like it's a lot of
retail demand
like you mentioned like robin hood
buyers and i think a lot of those people
haven't done
the research for tesla isn't that the
problem though is it and you talked
about it a second ago
and i was thinking why you said i was
like what a terrible learning
environment
in some ways trading is the worst way to
like it's such a bad
thing for your brain because as you said
you can
make in super intelligent decisions that
have the wrong or i mean have a negative
it's the wrong time or
a long time whatever but it had all the
backing
and then another guy can come in to test
the calls and they make like
they make like a hundred acts man the
number of comments i get like that
it i it's funny because early on
it was the same thing and yeah it was
the same thing with bitcoin it was the
same thing with
uh in canada i don't know if you have
that in the states but we had a weed
stock rally
when when we became legal in canada
and are actually leading up to when it
was becoming legal
but it's the same thing every time like
you know
it's people only care about what the
stocks recently done
um and you know we talked about tesla
like it's it's funny how many people
will comment
and say something like you know oh
tesla's not a car company they're
an energy company or they're a battery
company
and i kind of get what they're saying
but they make 90 of their revenues from
automobile sales so and i i don't know
if anyone knew
like knows that when they buy this stock
so it's stuff like that like i think
there's no excuse to not
know things like that um but
yeah it's important we're in a
results-driven world though and so it's
like it's terrible
it's terrible because at the end of the
day you can shout to your blue in the
face you should have known this this is
bad this is your
why are you even making this decision
and you're winning and so it's like well
they're waiting i don't know well that's
it it's like you go to a casino you tell
your friend
that roulette's a terrible game and they
double their money on red or something
and you know they're gonna laugh at you
for the rest of the day it's like well
that doesn't mean it was a good idea
um and the thing too you mentioned a bad
learning environment i i think
again going back to the idea that we've
we just finished the longest bull run in
us history
it will be really interesting to see
what happens when we have
a downwards decline and that's not to
say that one's
you know coming around the corner
although there's a lot of uh
warning signs right now but uh
you know we anyone who started trading
over just
and myself included we've been kind of
making money
yeah like like you you're you're kind of
uh isolated from
the realities of the stock market
because things have just done so well uh
but you have to remember like over this
10-year period starting from 2008
uh interest rates have been low uh
and the moment we get higher interest
rates the gravy train's gonna
slow down a bit um like we've just been
in this perfect environment for stocks
and that's not always going to continue
so anyone and and again i say myself
included
i'm fortunate because i talked to my
co-workers have been in
uh investing for their whole careers uh
and they tell me the horror stories of
the dot-com crash
um of you know going through 2008
so anyone who hasn't kind of learned
about those
crashes or or you know haven't had that
experience
they can't really say that that they're
a good investor or a good trader until
they've gone through those that full
cycle
of both a good time and that time
yeah in some ways it's like it's almost
like a crucible you gotta
it is what tests you as an investor and
you know people will come to me they go
hey steven your video about day trading
is wrong i say why
well because i'm making tons of money
day trading i always say the same thing
how long have you been day trading they
go oh six months
and it's like yeah you can't even
judging an investor's history really is
built on
five 10 15 years of course not on
six months or you know anyone can be a
genius or lucky for you know a month or
two
yeah and what do you think sorry sorry
what do you think go ahead
what were you going to say what were you
going to say go ahead i was just going
to say and uh
you know with things like uh when we had
the crazy bitcoin rally and like i said
we we have tesla bitcoin rally back in
2017
um where you know people who
put 800 bucks down on bitcoin got back
20 000.
like we we've just had some exceptional
examples that sort of convince people
that this is the normal way that stocks
work
um which is why i say like if you've
only invested like if you say six months
or we've only invested and traded for
three years you haven't experienced
everything you don't
fully know what the whole stock market
is like when you go through ups and
downs
so it's really led to a misleading under
misled understanding of
you know how stocks work and how the
market as a whole should return people
money over time
what do you think are lessons we should
learn from companies like uh
like nicola who
they're kind of these fast growing
companies a lot of hype a lot of
promises
they name themselves after tesla
what what are i can't i still find that
ridiculous
that that became a thing it's the future
uh
and then now it started to come out that
they were a bunch of hot air
and just a bunch of promises what do you
think about companies like i know i know
you probably can't speak to like whether
the stock is a fraud
because you have your own uh you know
your and
professional you can't say but do you
think there are lessons to be learned
from companies like this
there have been tons of companies like
it absolutely and
and you know i think it rings true
you know the idea that history repeats
itself i think one of the best things
someone who's
uh seriously interested in learning
about investing in trading themselves
one of the best things they can do is
learn about the history of the stock
market
um because the moment you learn a good
book for that know what i
i'm trying to think of a good one uh so
i've
done most of my learning through uh my
co-workers and then also
just going through online resources so i
haven't actually read a lot of books on
stuff like that
uh there's some covered in the cfa but
it's not a whole lot
it's kind of just like you know this
happened and it's like a couple
sentences
uh oh i'm trying to think of
there was one book my co-worker
recommended but i'll get it to you
afterwards
yeah sure sure sure but uh so
one like one book i read recently was uh
not flash boys what's the other one it's
by the guy who wrote the big short
man i am blanking on these books but uh
there's one book that talks about uh
now you know how you got called half
doughnut one final i know
i know under the big lights of
coffeezilla it gets intimidating
i know i know hard i it's uh
oh liars poker that's what it's called
uh so this is a book that talks about
1987 which was kind of a
and it talked about from the perspective
of one company which is solomon brothers
uh which was sort of the hotshot wall
street bond trader back in the day
uh like big cigars in the office uh
literally came out with like the kind of
scummy wolf of wall street culture
that you imagine when you think of these
companies back in the day
and uh they uh so
so the book talks about 1987 which was
kind of like not in a flash crash but
there was this big crash in the stock
market
and talks about all the crappy practices
that were happening before that
uh but you know i think anyone uh who
wants to learn about stocks should learn
about 1987 they should learn about the
dot-com crash
and i think there are so many
similarities between dot com and what
this we've seen over the past few years
because you mentioned nicola
um a big thing with uh
startups is there a lot higher risk
and not just because they don't
necessarily have a proven product
but because when we have an environment
like what we do where there's
all this pent up demand for these stocks
um that are you know selling electric
cars
or you know like i mentioned a few years
ago it was weed stocks
what happens is these companies start
cutting corners to try and get to the
front of that pack during normal times
people don't cut corners as much because
they're focusing on survivability
but when you have all this money waiting
for them you know
as long as they get that sales number
that they need and attract that
investor demand then that's where you
have
it's more likely for these companies to
come out and you know report these
problems
and i keep mentioning uh the weed stock
rally but it's
it had the exact same problem where you
know you had a few companies come out
they were doing well and then more and
more companies started coming forward
and saying we're going to be the number
one producer
in the world of marijuana like
like they were talking about exporting
internationally they were like canada is
going to be the hub
of um you know exporting experience well
that's exactly it and they were
and they were building the capacity to
do it they were like i don't remember
the numbers but it's ridiculous like
200 like million tons or something like
that of like just
marijuana that we're going to be
producing that might be an ex
exaggeration but i can't remember the
number it was something ridiculous and
like the world demand
or the demand for canada was less than
what they were saying they were going to
produce over time
but what happened was soon the lawsuits
started coming out where it's like oh we
found out this company
uh was producing without a license in
this extra warehouse
to try and cut those corners and i'm
pretty sure
like two of the top four companies had
some sort of regulatory
giant blow up running where you know one
of them even had their their sales
frozen i think
so it's just in that environment where
there's so much demand for this stuff
you have to be careful because and
that's where that fundamental research
becomes more important
and even then sometimes companies fake
stuff uh
so you can still do the fundamental
research and there's still that risk
that they're lying to you
um you know the numbers on their balance
sheet aren't accurate
uh they haven't been audited properly so
it's
i always treat companies and that's why
the value investor tries to avoid
those hot topic areas is because there's
just inherently more risk that comes
with that
uh and the companies might do well
uh you know people like to bring up
amazon as a good example
amazon was born in the dot com crash so
all these other companies went
bust and amazon kept going and they did
so well
but again you have to remember in the
numbers game that's not a very good
result when you have one company out of
hundreds
that survive the dot-com crash and did
well over time
and now people talk like oh this is just
like getting in
on amazon when it was you know a dollar
a share whatever it's like hey
buddy nobody knew amazon was going to be
the one
out of a hundreds stocks that at the
time looked almost identical
you know every no one believed in jeff
bezos at this point now it's easy to see
the guys
you know like and at the time it was you
know there's pets.com was
like the the big one that blew up like
you know
that one was like it came into the
market and then it left so quickly
because it got
like it kind of entered at the peak of
the dot-com crash and that's what you're
saying about seeing the history
is what you you need to basically have a
view of history
or a sense of it well i think fast if
you're someone like me who's only been
you know in the game for like five years
like that's not a lot of experience
um and not everyone has access to
like mentors who have been at it for
over 10 years
i really appreciate you saying that by
the way um
because you know you don't have a ton of
experience relatively
to what other traders have no yeah
you're open with openness with it is
very refreshing because one thing that
i'm totally sick of
is these people who've been trading for
a total of
two years three years pretending to be
experts there's no humility left there's
no
sense of there's actually value to being
in the game for 20 years or 30 years
and having seen those explosions and
learning from it
so when would you call yourself
an expert like i am an expert not a
you're a professional already
obviously yeah you really get the sense
of i
i really kind of have i know what i'm
doing or
are you going to be like uh i think
patrick boyle told me a story of
george soros one of the greatest traders
of all time
talking about how he's out of ideas i
don't know what i'm doing like
there's some people who they never feel
like they really got it all figured out
even though
some of them do that's that's a good
question uh man
when when like you mean like me
personally right like like when is it
personally when you have enough feathers
in your cap
to say it well i would certainly say it
takes going through
like i don't know like you've got to
have the experience i think
uh there's a saying in financial
services which is that gray hair goes a
long way
um which just means that it's tough to
make it as a financial advisor when
you're
20 something which is true and there's
reasons for that
but i think a lot of it is just
experience like you can learn everything
you want in terms of education
um and not be a good investor so
you know you've got to have the
credentials and you've got to have the
experience and
yeah i don't know it's tough because it
will depend how things go
uh i would say it's going to be at least
another decade until i feel like
i myself as like someone who works in
the field
am 100 up to speed with everything like
i
and even then i might not feel that way
you know i think uh
this is super douchey to say this
but like it makes uh there's an old
saying
uh story about socrates uh the
philosopher
and you know the idea of uh he admitted
he was a wise man
in athens because he was the only one
willing to admit that he didn't know
everything
and i think that goes a long way when it
comes to things like investments
sure um i don't think that's douchey to
say at all well
i i like i don't even pretend like i
know a lot about philosophy i have a
friend who talks about philosophy all
the time
oh you don't want to be a guy who's like
as socrates would say
exactly yeah but but
but the lesson's real right like it's
it's and there's that old
uh you know it's been proven by studies
that the less you know the more you
think you know
um and whereas oh that is certainly true
dunning-kruger is alive and well in
2012.
and it's it's you know for me it's kind
of like i'm experienced together i
have been experiencing the other end of
that where it's like the more i learn
the more i realize like
my god like this is such a vast universe
uh when it comes to investing
so it's not simple
yeah so let me ask you about okay
when i look at the the sort of investing
grades
um i usually see people who think
very independently of a lot of their
contemporaries
they're i don't know what you might call
them in another time before logan paul
we'd call them mavericks
he's kind of ruined that hasn't he uh
how do you develop that sense and do you
think that's reliable or do you think
maybe some of these people just got
lucky lucky like bill ackman just made a
big bet that paid him off
billions of dollars you know you have
some of these great investors with these
crazy stories george soros shorting the
pound right like uh
you've got these crazy things and
is that something your average investor
should be thinking about
or is it something that only those with
power and money should be trying to do
uh so it kind of goes back to the idea
of risk management like i don't think
the
average everyday joe investor should
expect or will ever see something like
that
on their account like there's some
there's certainly value in
um being willing to stick your neck out
like even just working for a company as
an analyst there's a lot of value to
being able to stick your neck out
to say this is what the market is saying
and this is
why i think it's wrong and this is why i
think this is a better bet and if you
can back that up
uh you know there could be an
opportunity there um
the problem is when you talk about like
shorting the pound
and these big bets that make billions
these people
are like not necessarily leveraging but
they have the capital to make that a
meaningful bet
whereas the average person like if
you're someone who for example
is uh in their 50s you
have like i don't know say 50 000 saved
up
you shouldn't be betting against uh
anything with all that money because you
don't
like you haven't even covered your bases
you can't afford to lose it anyways
exactly and meanwhile these millionaires
can right so they can go out and they
can
make these big bets uh which part
of the reason for it is a publicity
thing as well right like
you know these people love to draw the
attention because for their business
it kind of brings in that clientele if
it works out and if it doesn't work out
they just
pretend you know they don't bring it up
again yeah and also it can be a
self-fulfilling prophecy where if you're
on cnn
saying that you believe this stock is
going to crash
other investors are seeing that well oh
my gosh phil oh of course companies full
of it
well it's like warren buffett like
anything warren buffett says like
just becomes true because he's so and
yeah i know he almost doesn't need to be
an oracle anymore because he's exactly
everyone just follows him wherever he
goes
and and warren buffett too like you know
when you think about
what he advertises like himself as like
he never pretends to be
some omniscient person who knows
everything like and
in fact like when it comes to companies
like because people love to point this
out like
uh when it comes to tech stocks like he
has a poor track record
when it comes to tech stocks and
investing in tech stocks but the reason
he doesn't touch those companies is
because he says firsthand like he
doesn't have the expertise to understand
those companies
so he basically puts a bunch of stocks
into a i don't understand this pile
and doesn't even worry about it so you
know
it's but going back to the original
point like
i don't know it's it's one of those
things where i think before you can have
these big
you know this big pipe dream of making
that big call and stuff like that
uh first of all there are these other
forces that play when it comes to
marketing and things like that
and second of all the people who make
these big calls are usually the ones
with the capital to lose
um the average person doesn't have that
and you know
like just as an example um
man you're right about the donut thing
uh
i steve eisemann that's his name uh one
of the guys
oh you mean it's hard to remember it's
hard to remember names yeah
uh but steve eisemann i i'm pretty sure
that's his name
um he's one of the guys who's actually
portrayed by uh
in the big short movie he's one of the
people who bet against the 2008
financial crisis
like he made a bunch of money with real
estate um
since then one of his other big bets has
been actually
so uh he's a canadian and his one of his
big bets is against
uh canadian banks um
and you know there's a whole bunch of
different reasons why but basically it
comes down to there's a lot of debt in
canada um and for the past
decade it's been proven wrong now it's
not to say he's not a smart guy
that's not to say that there are not
problems with canadian people that's a
bad result
but it's it's about exactly that's
exactly it so you know
sometimes you can do all the research
and you still get that bad result
and so you know we but who knows that he
made this bet right
we all know that he made or the people
who know of steve eisemann know that he
made this big bet
against real estate in 2008. they don't
know about this other bet that hasn't
panned out yet
um and that being said it might pan out
with a pandemic who knows
but it just goes to show like it's a lot
harder to make these big claims
uh than it seems you know a lot of the
people they keep making these claims and
then one of them eventually sticks
oh and they go see look i called it and
it's like
you're wrong with the other 10 things i
know i can't tell you how many
i can't tell you how many people go i
predicted the 2008 crash and you're like
when where how and my
correct i had an uncle who claimed to
who said he did that too and it's like
well where's the money
well also predicting the 2008 crash in
2005
isn't predicting the 2008 crash because
people be like oh yeah that stock
the the stock market is going to take in
2005. and then by the time 2008 cr
like crashed they were back invested in
the market and it's like oh well
you didn't you were just pointing out
what everyone already knew which is that
eventually bull bull runs have to end
but yeah he didn't
predict anything like if we see a stock
market crash we're gonna have so many
people saying they came and predicted
this
stock market crash it's like well like a
did you put your money where your mouth
is and back up like are you shorting the
market right now which
i'm not saying you should do that i'm
just saying like if you're going to make
these claims you need to
support it and you know put your money
where your mouth is yeah and a lot of
people just
you know everything hindsight is 20 20.
you know
so do you think there's a place for
a a um service
that audits traders who are not
institutional
investors like and
basically they were the gold star of
investing and it's like if you could
show
this then we sort of know you're legit
i think it has to come out with how many
people are claiming crazy things
how unreliable it is um there
has to be a service where it's like they
don't just
ask for one thing they do a deep
audit of your finances and they really
kind of rip you to shreds
and then come up with like a score well
i think
that currently exists in the form of
having a registered business
uh but like in terms of like auditing
traders
like it's something i would like to see
happen i don't know if if it ever will
because
then you get into the argument of
infringing on infringing on privacy
things like that and
again these people are walking that fine
line right where they say
you know we say these things but we're
not promising that we're going to make
you this money
uh they're just you know they're making
they're heavily implying that you can
get a lamborghini if you
if you buy their 500 course so it's it's
a really tough gray area and i'd like to
see
more i guess a clampdown
for lack of a better word because a lot
of it too has just been as social media
has evolved
we haven't seen the regulations and when
it comes to things
yeah they haven't caught up right
exactly that's very true
so richard what do you think about i
mean we've sort of covered
technical analysis retail trading what
do you think about day trading and forex
the new
hotness on the block these are two
different things obviously
but uh they're both kind of if you see
an investor
selling investing they're probably
selling one of those two
day trading and forex why is that
is it something about the like it's just
the new sexy thing
no one's teaching warren buffett
technically i know yeah
it's not as sexy as as uh you know
people
want when it comes to stocks and stuff
but so
a big thing with uh so day trading can
involve
anything and day trading can be 4x like
there is sort of a
like a mutual aspect there but uh you
can do day trading with stocks you can
do day trading with cryptocurrencies
whatever
by the way the comments are gonna flame
me i know
that investing and trading are different
everyone knows you know what that's
really
i get that too a lot actually you know
because i i sometimes use them
synonymously
but it's yeah they are different but
they
they are different but at the end of the
day you can also
measure performances similarly you can
measure how much something
they're the same universe like it's it's
the same yes but we
we know that warren buffett is an
investor a value investor we know that
there are day traders doing something
else we get it
okay i gotta put that out there because
i like people like do you know and i'm
like yeah no i know i
yeah no exactly and and but so when it
comes to day trading
and forex uh the big thing
is people market them as being a lot
having a lot more potential for return
but the reason for that
is um there is a lot of leverage
involved
so with day trading for example a common
day trading instrument is options
uh which you know as opposed to buying
the stock you buy a contract that is
leveraging your return so if it goes up
one dollar you experience more than a
dollar return
um based on how much you put in right
and
so the problem with leverage is it's it
goes both ways where
um you increase your return potential
but you also increase how much you can
lose
it's basically borrowing money to invest
so that if things go well you make more
money because you have more to invest
and you pay back the debt
but if you lose money then you earn your
losses
and you have to pay back that money you
borrow so it's like a double whammy
that way um and the thing with forex
specifically
is i don't know the exact numbers but
you can leverage to a ridiculous amount
like i think you can go
back yeah exactly and and so what that
means is
like for one dollar i you can invest 100
more or less and so if that 100 dollars
turns into 200
you make like i'm trying to do the math
but something like 99 dollars
on that on that bro one dollar yeah on
your one dollar
so that's leverage right and that's
leveraged from extreme the thing they
don't tell you is that you can lose a
lot more than just one dollar
i you might have just put that one
dollar but you can lose like
you know again i not doing the math but
something like around negative 100
on that same trade um if not more if you
do something like a short position
so yeah also a lot of these things just
stop you out instantly if the market
just fluctuates even
the yeah that's the fraction of a point
they'll just stop out your account and
then you lose everything
yeah and that's a good point because you
might and again same thing you might be
right
you might say uh you know you might make
a big bet like i'm going to short
uh mcdonald's or something and
they might drop or they might increase
in price by like 20
and you'll be forced to realize that
loss even if
next year they do drop um you still lost
money because
the the broker or whoever's involved is
forcing you to realize that loss because
they're
saying hey we want to take this guy's
money before
he goes insolvent if this keeps going up
he's going to not have enough money to
pay us back
what he owes us so they're going to
close the position and say okay your
liabilities cut here
pay us the amount you owe us and even if
you end up being right you might still
lose money on that
so that's a problem with using leverage
is you have that extra risk where you
might be forced to exit a position
before your thesis even plays out
do you think new investors should be
working with options in leverage or do
you think it's
it's like a more tool it is more
sophisticated there's more
but the biggest thing is that there's
more risk um
you know leverage is really something
that if you're
saving for uh you know to pay off your
student loans you shouldn't be using
leverage like
it's something that most professionals
will never
even with a wealthy client will never
use for their clients
so a lot of people get by with
traditional financial methods never
touching a dollar of leverage
um so if you're someone who's starting
off and you're a beginner and you don't
have that fundamental
understanding of stocks no you should
definitely stay away like it's just
added risk that takes a lot more extra
care
um and yes it and that's the thing too
is when you have these people who are
self-proclaimed millionaires
they might be that person who took that
crazy leveraged position
and won that one position you know made
that million dollars
so that's the thing is i don't actually
go out and try to disprove that people
haven't made the millions they say they
have sure maybe they have
but i i don't believe they can repo they
can replicate that you're just saying
enough traders in the market someone's
to make it big on the bet they're going
to win the jackpot of vegas
but it doesn't mean they're going to win
it every time exactly i think
we hear from the from the 0.01 percent
that make it and
nothing from the 99.99 who lost
everything you sound like a big fan of
burton malkia
i don't know where that is oh you don't
know oh my gosh
no who's that burton what's his name
random walk down wall street oh yes
sorry i have that book
i didn't recognize his name yeah so i
was about to say
yeah you're like basically quoting his
big thesis
no yeah no i have that book and and
that's that's the thing too
is is uh you know i'm an active investor
so i'm someone who
in my job i research companies and i
pick individual companies i think are
going to do well
but the other side of that is passive
investing which is
the vanilla plain vanilla you're just
going to buy the index fund hello
and do well over here yeah no no that's
what i do
and that's the thing is is i think uh
there are definitely ways to go wrong
with active management and some ways to
go wrong with passive management
i'm not one to say that i think passive
management is not i invested passively
when i started off
um and it's something that i have a lot
of respect for that field actually
because i think
passive management has in a lot of ways
empowered a lot of people to get into
investing
at a very low cost with uh not needing a
whole lot of expertise
so that's the thing too is to consider
is is
you know if you're someone who's
starting off you don't have the
expertise
you might not even need to be an active
investor like you could look into these
passive investing options where
you take a lot less risk because you're
diversified
one thing that i like about it besides
just the low
maintenance uh not merely in terms of
fees but in terms of
time mostly is that it totally
eliminates the
emotional proposition of investing which
is i think extremely valuable for people
who are not professional traders
because i i don't have to look at it i
can just i
i have the luxury of just turning my
head and just being like yeah i don't
really care
um because it's going to go down today
up tomorrow
eventually all i care about is the end
result and i think that's
would be something that's valuable for a
lot of people who you might think you're
totally in control of your emotions
but when you see your stock dip 20
it's hard to really get a hold of
yourself sort of um
and so i think that's one of the
positives of passive investing now i
think you made a video
either this or this was the half
doughnut that i was talking about
you made a video about the passive index
bubble
right did you yeah so yes that that was
actually and speaking of people making
tall claims that was michael bury
uh the guy played by christian bale in
the big short so like the main character
of the big short who also bet against
real estate
that was about an article that that guy
had
come forward again and said this is
going to be the next big bubble
is the etf bubble because so many people
are investing just sort of mindlessly
into
passive funds and it may just be
sustaining these stocks
even when they don't aren't actually
worth what they
propose to be worth is that basically
the thesis yeah more or less like it's
it's the idea that
uh you know as if people like let's say
100
of the market like everyone who has
money buy stocks
but they don't do any research they just
buy a bit of everything
the idea is that you don't have what's
called price discovery which is
people going and doing the research and
saying hey these two stocks should
be the same value because this one is
actually making money this one's losing
money it has a bunch of debt
um so the idea is if you have too many
people passively investing you don't
have the right price discovery
um and you're going to inflate any
company that's included in that index
so there's i think it's called the index
premium which is something that some
research papers have proven some have
disproven so
it's up in the air whether it's real or
not but at least
initially when a company joins an index
it tends to see a boost in its stock
price
oh just because there's so many so many
index investors
yeah so part of it could be that people
see it as a stamp of approval that this
company has reached a level of maturity
but some people argue that it's because
there are passive investors who are just
buying whatever enters that index
and there's i mean there's definitely
truth to that but do you think this is a
a problem that will have its own bubble
i mean do you believe in that
thesis of the passive index bubble uh
myself like i i always try to you know
take a very
like i don't try to say yes or no to
anything like everything's pretty
everything's possible personally i don't
think we're going to see
like a crash in etfs because of passive
investing
i think that as you have
passive investors kind of misallocating
money to different stocks
we might see a correction which is where
you know we see like a 10 drop
in stocks like you know that are
inflated which
uh companies that might be inflated
because of
indices would include companies like uh
at the top of the s p 500 so that's your
amazon your facebook
uh those companies they might see a
correction where
you know because it gets to a certain
point eventually people realize hey
these are too expensive
uh like you have those active investors
who kind of deviate from the hurt
and will change people's mind about it
so i think there's enough of a mark
like i don't think we'll ever see 100
passive investing
and on top of that like when you i
actually forget many of the points i
made in that video but when you
look at the um number of trades in the
market a lot of it is still active
uh so we haven't reached a point where
for example even 50
of the market is passive it's nowhere
near that point right now
so it's something that you know maybe in
the future we have a bigger problem but
i think um in the world of robin hoods
it's actually sort of there's just
nothing sexy about passive
investing um just like there's nothing
emotionally scary about it there's
nothing that's sort of the problem
isn't it is that it's there's nothing
kind of like oh my gosh what could
happen yeah
i would say we're certainly at a bigger
risk of a of a retail investor bubble
than an etf bubble right now like i
think because of things like robinhood
where
we've reduced commissions uh people can
buy and sell for no cost
and it's incredibly accessible now
versus before you had to call someone
to whenever you want to buy something
it's just a click away
um i think that that's led to a lot of
these people who
you know and again when we have these
rallies and companies like tesla
it's it attracts all these these newbies
i guess who
don't have the the research the
expertise behind it using these
platforms to
buy in and i think that's a much larger
risk right now
um and you know if you group that under
the
active management style which uh you
know
sure you could do that because they're
actively choosing their stocks but they
aren't doing the research to support it
so it's kind of like the
like a combination of the two problems
right you have people who are
picking and choosing stocks regardless
of the index but they also aren't doing
the research like the proper research in
vetting so
i think that's a much bigger problem
i'd have to i'd have to definitely agree
with you do you think
people are going to lose their shirts
when interest rates
go up or i mean it's inevitable right i
mean they've been slashed for so long
but i don't know i don't know that's
like
that's fascinating to me yeah it's it's
tough because
certainly there's going to be a slow
down like it's just
not the way the market works when
interest rates rise uh
stocks tend to lose in a bubble of
optimism like it's it's
it's insane era of nothing's ever gonna
change the sun always shines in the
stock market it's like
the pandemics happening how is the s p
still it's crazy
it is crazy and i think you know
something people need to remember with
stuff like the s p 500 is it's not
a proper gauge of the stock market it's
really a gauge of the
of the top stocks in the stock market
and the top stocks right now
are again those facebooks those amazons
that to some degree have actually
benefited from a pandemic
you know you think of an amazon my god
like how many small businesses have they
just trampled over because they've just
eaten
up they their their world domination
was just accelerated bezos is smiling
yeah well that's
and that's it so you know is the stock
market doing well because amazon's up
like
i don't know i there are other uh
indices out there like the russell
indices uh in canada we have our own
indices as well but
like there are other gauges and i would
say that when you look at
other like especially if you look at
certain areas like you know
tourism uh companies like that uh
these companies have not done well um so
but you know i agree like i think
it's a crazy time for the stocks like i
think we're in this weird
phase where people are more optimistic
than they are pessimistic about the
future regardless of the fact that
we're all working from home like we're
all stuck at home during a pandemic
yeah what do you do you think it's
arrogant of people to think
that oh this is going to be my big time
to place a big bet on the stock market
or do you think yeah fair enough some
people are gonna make fortunes some
people are gonna lose them
yeah it's it's again it's one of those
things i i would be more inclined to the
second to the latter
just because i think like it's so hard
to tell and
you know i say all these things about
the market and yet i i still
won't stand down and say i think a
recession is coming or well we're in a
recession but
i won't come and say i think a stock
market crash is happening i think we'll
have a slow down eventually i think
that you know we've had a long period of
low interest rates
uh we've had a long period of things
like stock buybacks that have really
uh boosted earnings of these companies
earnings figures
and i think at some point you know after
these companies have borrowed so much
money you know debts at an all-time high
in some
metrics that just can't keep going like
if you fueled this growth with debt
there's a cap that you reach and we're
probably getting close to that cap
so maybe once we get to that point
things kind of
stay flat for a bit and and the
fundamentals get a time to catch up
or maybe things drop but you know i
that's it like it's you never know and i
think the moment you think you know
you've lost
so that's a kind of mentality i try to
keep
that's really great way to end it thank
you so much richard for coming on the
show i appreciate it hey thanks for
having me
expertise it was fun and if you guys
want to find him go to half doughnut no
i'm just kidding
go to the plain bagel on youtube i'll of
course
link him up i got the mug and
you know i i will include some
descriptions
in the description some resources that
richard uh sends me
of various places you can get started
with investing
i know that many people are you know
stuck at home they want to get an
education during the pandemic i think
that's great
and so we will include some resources
just like we did with the patrick boyle
video
thank you guys for watching see you next
[Music]
time
[Music]
you